and it's also all love all the time over
it's a good place on NBC Kristen Bell
makes sure of that
just don't be jerk we're so lucky to be
here especially in a job like this where
we're doing comedy there's like no
excuse there's no [ __ ]
I thought we would say yeah on the show
every single person on set is nice and
funny a rare combination Kristen's no
jerks rule is just one of the reasons
why this is the good place and the fact
that these onset shenanigans happen is
another in spite of all the fun they're
having Kristen says thanks to series
creator Mike sure she already knows how
the series will end kinda I barely
remember what he said because my memory
is just my I've the worst memory in the
world so I'm a great secret keeper yeah
because I don't remember the secret
nor will I judge you for it but yes he
has thrown out some ideas that would
happen should we wrap the show up in
seven years we're calling afterlife
memories here on earth has some
significant side effects tonight's
episode is all about repressed memories
meanwhile in real life Ted and Kristen
are making their own memories to last a
lifetime I heard that she took you to an
escape room we were there with my wife
Mary and her husband Dax can you add one
flashlight for each group well I gave
the flashlight to Dax yeah and notice
that there was a clot in our self
stretched out and took a nice little
dose for the 20 minutes of took we
didn't get out but everyone else was
bummed out I was rested happy as a clam
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]